- I'm X.
- I'm Dixon.
- And this is Academy Green Room.
(upbeat music)
- It's a special day today.
Firstly because I have on
makeup and if I have on makeup,
that means it's a special day today.
- You know it's something real.
It's also a special day because I'm here
with an Oscar nominee.
Oscar nominated for best song,
singer,
vocal arranger, producer,
musician, and now Oscar nominee
for best song for "Be Alive."
Co-written and sung by none
other than Queen B, Beyonce.
Dixon welcome man.
Peace, congratulations by the way.
- Thank you man.
- How are you feeling?
- I'm feeling good, man.
You know, it's this the big weekend.
- I just really want to
know your story, man.
How did you get here?
And I don't mean, did you get a lift
or did you get an Uber here,
or did Kenny back there at
home and drive you here?
How did you get here?
- I mean just a lot of faith and patience.
Honestly, I can't really
take too much credit
for my own talents.
I feel like those are a gift from God.
But patience is something
you have to learn,
and faith is something
you have to practice.
- That's real.
- I've done both of those things.
And so I think it's a
good time for those things
to start working.
- All right, we better start
unpacking some of this stuff.
You gonna give some stuff
and I'm gonna throw it right back to you.
So you said patience.
Tell me about something you went through
that gave you patience
to get to this moment.
Because I don't want
people to just see Dixon,
this amazing producer and
you're at the Oscars, right?
It just didn't just happen this way.
Some things happen a along
the way to get you here.
- Yeah, I guess one
thing that happened was
I had to be in the background for a while.
- How did that feel?
- I mean, it felt great
because I was feeding my family
and taking care of myself.
I don't ever complain about those moments
because they really shaped me and made me
the professional that I am.
To be quite honest I signed
a record deal back in 2019
and I was still on the road
as a background singer.
So those two worlds
happening at the same time.
Working on my own solo projects,
and then supporting artists
who were ahead of me
in their careers, sometimes that dichotomy
was a struggle because
you believe in yourself
and you want people to
see what you're doing
as a solo artist.
But it's like it hasn't
really taken off there yet.
So you gotta support.
And I really don't sign up to do things
that I don't fully believe in.
And so the artists that I've
been fortunate to work with
in a more background capacity,
I believe in their work and
I've always been in service
to what they do.
And so it worked out for me.
Because that patience coupled
with a bit of humility made me
who I am.
- How'd you get to that space where
you were doing background vocals
for these different artists
and who were some of these artists?
- I started off with Vic Mensa.
Who's a label made of mine now,
and one of my really close friends.
I started off with him and
that was kind of on a whim.
I met him through Pharrell.
And Pharrell was like, you'all
need to know each other.
And he put out this project
called Autobiography.
And I called and I was like,
do you got anybody singing
background with you on the road?
And really it was just, I
was trying to get out there.
And he didn't.
And so I just showed up to rehearsal
and had my little rig
going and he walked in
and it was just like a match.
And so I toured with him for a while.
And through that I met
Chance, Chance the Rapper.
- Y'all have adult collaboration
with Nicki Minaj as well.
You wanna talk about that too?
- Yeah I mean, I started working
with Chance in the studio.
I didn't plan to tour with him.
And honestly the real
story is around 2019,
my father had passed away in June.
- My condolences.
- And thank you man, I appreciate that.
And I knew I had spent all my money
to bury my father basically.
And I was like, I need work.
And so luckily the timing was right.
He called me to do one song,
just some vocal arrangement.
And he loved it so much that
they invited me to Chicago
to work on the album.
And so my plan was to literally work.
He has an incredible
organization called Social Works.
I was gonna work the
summer camp during the day
to make money, and at
night work on the album.
- And we're talking about
less than three years ago.
- Yeah, and I was fine with that.
I told my girlfriend I was like,
listen, whatever I gotta do
to make sure the lights is on
I'll work in the summer camp,
be with the kids during the day.
And then on night time hit
at the studio and just hope
I don't pass out at work.
- The next morning.
And it just kind of happened
that he wanted to tour.
And so instead of doing the summer camp,
I went from the studio
to just be on the road.
I think my first show with him
was like in London somewhere.
And I was in the studio
I get the call like,
do you wanna go?
And I was literally on a
plane to London to sing back
and the rest has kind of
been history with him.
- So how did you get to the
point from almost working
at summer camp, being on a
road in London with Chance,
doing stuff with Vic Mensa
and then getting to the point
where you're producing and
co-writing with Beyonce.
One of the biggest artists of all.
- I can't really say it's
like a secret to this.
It's just you gotta really
believe in what you do.
and then commit to being in service to it.
I tell people all the time
like I'm in service to music.
So when I get called to do something,
I'm fully a hundred percent in.
Like sign me up.
Obviously if we say yes to the opportunity
I try not to take too many
things on at one time.
Because my manager who's
off camera will tell you,
I tend to do that.
But when I'm in, I'm fully in.
And so I've just been in
service and I made up in my mind
during the pandemic I was like,
I'm just gonna keep
submitting songs to be.
And see what happens.
And so I would write something,
I'd be like, okay that feels good for us.
I would just send it off.
And I didn't think she had heard anything.
- I was gonna ask you, did
you ever get any feedback?
- Not really anything
- Anything just
- Not really not until we
got the call for the movie.
And I was like, oh she's heard things.
And thinks I'm a good candidate
for writing this song.
And so immediately I just
dove in and we're here.
- Did you bug out when you got the call?
- I freaked out a bit.
I take what I do seriously,
but then you get some calls and it's like,
you just kind of gotta
laugh about it, like really?
It's super unbelievable.
That was definitely one of those moments
where I had to pinch myself.
- And what was the process like?
Like what was that process
of now you've gotten the call
from Beyonce's camp and you
guys are actually sitting down
to do the songwriting for
you to produce the record.
What is that like?
- The process was quick, to be honest.
We didn't have much time to get it in.
So I came here to LA and
day one, I just did a demo.
- You came up like, did
they talk about the concept?
I wanna know.
- I hadn't really seen much of the movie.
- Okay, and did they
tell you about the movie?
- I knew about the story.
So I knew about obviously knew about it,
Serena, Venus, and their
father and how much of a role
he played in their lives.
I saw the trailer,
and that's when everything
started to hit me.
Because if you know Beyonce's story,
she also had a father who
was very instrumental.
- Strong black father.
- In her life.
I myself had a very
strong father in my life.
- You mentioned him off camera,
but when we hadn't started.
- Yeah, so he's a quite
instrumental in my life
and how I approach my life.
I take a lot of what he taught
me with me on a daily basis.
And so I knew this part of
the story and I was like,
well this part will be
the easiest part to write.
Now we just have to make something
that is captivating enough
for the directors of
the film and the studio.
- And they feel like it
should be a part of a movie.
- Yeah, and so it really
just started with guitars,
me sitting down on a couch
and just plucking through like
the first initial versus.
I recorded the demo.
I want to say it took me
about like two or three hours
and I felt good.
I was going to bounce it out,
take it home, listen to
it, make my own notes.
And then I see around the
studio some commotion happening
and I'm like, oh my God.
- Now what was this commotion?
- Well, she came to the
studio while I was working.
- And I wasn't quite done with the record.
I mean looking back on it,
I was more done than I thought I was.
But as creatives a lot of
times we get in our head.
- You're working on forever.
Let's talk it.
Somebody gotta snatch the record at you.
- Kenny often is like,
no, you're gonna release this version.
But now she came while I was working on it
and I played it for it her.
But I didn't look at her the whole time
that I was playing for her.
- But that's awkward too.
When you're playing music for somebody
to be the creator of it.
I've been on the other side.
So I've been the person
in the room so many times,
working at Spotify,
working at record labels.
And I'm in there listening to the music
and the artist is there and I'm like,
damn, this is awkward for both of us.
You know what I mean?
And you're like, how hard do I nod my head
or do I look at them
while I'm listening to it?
So it's usually this, you kind of nod.
- I didn't turn that
chair around one time.
I was also very nervous
because I hadn't bounced
the song out of pro tools yet.
So I was nervous.
I was gonna press the wrong button
if made any some movements.
It wasn't my personal gear either.
So I didn't feel very comfortable.
So I didn't move.
And when I turned around,
she had a big smile on her face
and she immediately came out of the gate,
giving me notes and everything else.
So we just first demoed
down and she gave her notes
and then took the record with her
and did her own rewrites
and reproductions.
And then I got it back.
And I mean when I got it
back, it was so magical.
But then I was encouraged to keep digging
and keep carving at it to
make sure her that it was what
I wanted also.
I think that's what's really special
about working with Beyonce.
Honestly people don't talk enough about
who she is as a songwriter and a producer.
But I also think it's very
generous of her to allow me
to keep carving at it when she's
so good at what's she does.
Honestly, we have these legacy artists
and we hear all these
stories about how tough it is
to work with them, for them.
- They won't bend or they
won't accept like feedback
or collaboration way.
It's like, no, I got it from here.
- Yeah, but I think B
is a creative honestly,
and she respects other creatives.
And I think that's what
makes her music so magical.
Is that she's allowing
people to be themselves
within her world.
- So timely, I think
one of her the hallmarks
of her career up to this
point is collaboration.
And that's what keeps her relevant.
- She's so good at it.
- She's looking for the next person.
We got a question from the
audience I want to go through.
They ask, is this the most
nervous you've ever been
to work with an artist?
- Probably so, I think this
was the most nervous I've been
just because with her you
want to get it really right.
It's her and Pharrell might
have been like the most
because with them obviously
they're very busy people
and you don't want to ever feel like
you're wasting their time.
And so yes, I was extremely nervous.
- And audience keep questions coming.
You can ask whatever you want.
This is the conversation
of me and Dixon kick in.
And I'm just gonna keep on
digging into this story.
So she bet you keep tweaking
with it, keep pulling from it.
When did you know this is it?
This is the version.
So I played around with
many versions of this song.
And I think the moment I knew
that it was the right one,
I got a note from her team that said
she might be interested in
going back a couple versions
to the original one.
And I was like okay, I've
done all these tweaks.
And this is like just a message
for creatives, honestly.
Sometimes your original
version is the version.
- It's the one.
- I can already see Kenny's
face off to the side.
I know he's like for
real, that's how you feel?
But sometimes your original
version is the version.
That's what happened with this record.
I think the intention
of the original demo,
it was so straightforward and
straight ahead that anytime
we tried to over embellish
something, it did too much.
That's a message for creative.
Sometimes you got it on the
first one and don't overthink it
- Trust your instinct.
- Yeah, trust your instinct.
And then when you get
confirmation from somebody like B,
that your instinct was right,
then you kind of feel good.
- You're like see, I told you Kenny.
All right, we got another
question from the audience.
You work with the queen, who
do you wanna work with next?
Can it get any better?
- There's not really a better singer.
But there are plenty of
artists I want to work with.
I really wanna work with Kendrick.
I think I wanna do
something really theatrical
with Kendrick.
Because I feel like he's such
a great performer obviously,
but the way he delivers
things is really special.
And I think that he has
so many different versions
of himself as an artist.
And I want to tap into
this more theatrical side
of Kendrick.
Obviously Rihanna is high on the list.
I think we all just want
music from her honestly.
- We all do.
Can we get this dancehall album please?
Can we get something, anything?
- Yeah, Rihanna is a big one on the list.
There's a lot of new artists
too that I really love.
I'm a new artist myself.
So I champion new artist.
I love Cimino.
I think Cimino is a prolific
writer and performer.
I really love Lucky Daye.
I think he's one.
- Me too, I talk about
Lucky Daye all of the time.
- He's one of the best writers
writing songs right now.
- Loving the new album?
- I do love the new album.
- It's great.
- As a writer, I get to hear demos a lot.
Every time I hear a Lucky demo,
I'm like this man is just so prolific.
So I love Lucky, I hope one
day we get to work together
and do some songs together.
Yeah, I love her obviously.
What a gift?
What a talent?
So the new artist get a lot of love too.
Drake is big on my list
too because I feel like
that's another artist who
has many versions of himself.
- I mean he can do almost any style.
- He really can.
And Drake also can really sing,
I don't care what anybody says.
I love singing Drake just as
much as I love rapping Drake.
So that would be really cool
to work with him for sure.
- Do you feel like you made it?
- I tend to not think about it often.
Like I said, this is my job
and like what a crazy job to have.
You get to wake up every
morning and do exactly
what you love doing.
There's little things inside the job
that give you certain
stresses and things like that
- By definition of a job.
Those things are gonna be there
- Yeah but what a crazy life
I get to live as a musician,
and a producer and I get paid for it.
And you I can live the way
I've always dreamed living.
So I don't think about making it.
I think making it for me
is just being able to do
what you love freely.
And a lot of people don't
have that opportunity.
And so I'm extremely grateful every day
that I get to do this
because a lot of people
don't get to do it.
And there's a lot of people
that are high up at their jobs,
but they're not doing what they love.
- That's right.
- But they do it because
they have to provide
and they have to make life
happen for themselves.
I'm just one of the lucky
ones that get to do it
and it's exactly what I want to do it.
- Sounds like you living in a moment.
- Oh yeah, every day.
- How'd you get to a place in your life
where you could just live
in a moment like that.
- I think in 2019, I
lost a lot of relatives.
I lost my father,
and my grandfather, my
brother and my sister
all in one year.
And I think that's when I was like,
no, if I'm a live, I'm a live now.
Because I don't want any regrets.
And I remember, my father was diagnosed
with cancer like three
years before he passed.
So I got to spend three years literally
just right next to of him.
And I mean this is a guy
who accomplished quite a bit
in his time on the earth.
But there were still
moments that I could feel
that he had regret.
And he would constantly remind me,
son if you're going to do something,
don't do it with any regrets.
Just go for it and live as
big and as bold as you can.
And don't cower for anybody telling you,
you can't do that.
So that watching him go through that,
I just decided for
myself I'm gonna do this.
- Basically, you gonna
live while you here.
- Got to, there's no other way to do it.
Money is a tool, it comes and it goes.
But your life is the most
valuable thing that you have,
so you gotta live it.
- I tell people the money will come.
Go after what you love, make
sure you're eating every day.
But the money will come.
It'll all come together.
I gotta question from a young songwriter,
was there something you
wish someone told you
at the beginning of your career?
- As a songwriter,
I wish someone would've told
me how valuable learning,
how to produce was.
Early on in my career, I
always was making my own beats.
But I think if you're a
really good songwriter
and people love what you do,
they're gonna call you in
the room to do just that.
And what ends up
happening in this business
is that songwriters get stuck in a cadence
of just being songwriters.
- And not being able to shape
the whole sound of the song.
- In a lot of ways they are shaping
the whole sound of the song,
but the title makes them
only one piece of it.
So I think I wish someone had
told me earlier in my life
that I could demand because I'm shaping
the sound of the song vocally,
when I could become a vocal producer.
We obviously know the
industry works like this,
the songwriters they get paid later.
- Through the publishing .
- Through the Publishing that's right.
But producers get paid up front.
Vocal producers get paid up front.
So if you're a great
songwriter and you can sing
and you're creating and
shaping these worlds
with your melodies,
the best thing I could tell
you is demand production.
And I know it's not a popular take,
but it's a hot take for me.
I wish somebody would've told me
when I was younger that I
could demand production credits
for what I was doing.
- All right, so I'm a breakfast person
and the listeners out there
know I'm big with breakfast.
No matter what time my day starts.
I knew it as soon as I saw you.
- Breakfast it's we just had it.
- So you already know the answer to this,
but the question is, does
Dixon eat French toast?
Because I do have a fire recipe.
- Yes, I do eat French toast
more than I would like to admit.
- I had some this morning.
- I love French toast.
I do not make great French toast.
- I got you.
- My girlfriend,
- Hers though?
- is out of control
- you don't need me?
- I mean you should just come over
and then taste everybody's French toast.
- Oh, let's do that.
All right, let's set that up.
I'm coming through, Kenny has my contacts.
- Kenny likes French toast too.
- Oh, I Know Kenny like toast.
Kenny look like he like French toast?
- Oh my God, we love breakfast.
- What does success look like to you?
- Success it's a very nuanced thing.
Because on most days you just feel like
you are working with your head down.
Like that's what success feels like to me,
getting the call.
And people wanting me
around to do the thing
that I'm called to do you.
Honestly, that's what it feels like to me.
Every time I get a call,
or my management, or my
assistant gets a call
and they're like, they
wanna work with you.
That feels like success to me.
Which is a different approach.
I have a lot of friends in this business
that look at success in a different way.
But I think it's not just
about being in demand.
It's I think people by virtue
of learning who you are
as a creative when they
continue to call you
to show up for things.
That's success for me.
Obviously the awards and
everything are a nice added bonus.
But at the end of the day I
got in this business to work.
- So when my phone is
ringing, I feel successful.
- Yeah, because one thing
set up the next thing.
And it shows you that
you're gonna keep working.
It's a reminder that
I'm gonna keep working.
- That this is my forever career
and I don't mind taking breaks,
but I rarely take them
because I love the work.
And that's success for me.
Just being constantly able to work.
When I look at artists
who I'm obsessed with
and that I love,
they're constantly doing something.
And they've learned how to
pivot and create a world
for themselves where they can keep working
and that's success for me.
- Now we all need balance.
And that's something I'm
personally working on that
that work life balance it's hard.
You mentioned that you
don't say yes to everything.
If you're gonna work on something,
you're gonna put your all into it.
It's gonna get your focus.
How do you know what to say no to?
- Well I mean, not to be too deep
but I generally pray about.
- Just get out deep as we need to.
- Yeah, I generally pray about things.
- I do too.
- Before I go into anything.
Whether it's a deal,
or it is a song, or whether
it's a block of time
that I have to give up
to do something else..
I honestly pray and then I seek guidance.
So I mean, I've been very fortunate.
I worked most of my career by myself.
But this days I have a team of people.
one person on my team, my manager Kenny
has been in the industry for a long time.
So I always seek guidance there.
First and foremost, I have
a lawyer who's incredible.
So I seek guidance on whether
I'm gonna get stuck in something.
Or whether we can move, pivot
And then my assistant man is
one of the most creative people
I've ever worked with.
And he just always has sound advice
about like my spirit.
He's like, what tax is it
going to take on your spirit?
- I love that question.
- And so he's usually the
third person I talk to
and he's like, do you
really want to do this?
Or do you feel like you're
gonna be missing out?
Because that FOMO is very real.
You always have to take into consideration
the tax something is
gonna take on your soul
and your spirit.
Talking with my wise counsel
that's how I make decisions on things.
I have tried a lot
especially in the last year,
because things have just been really busy
to not make decisions
completely on my own.
That will derail something
that might be happening
internally with my team.
where I usually try to pick
up the phone and call somebody
and be like, Hey this
is what's on the table.
What should we do?
Or Kenny calls me and
like, we got this thing.
I'll talk to him about what he thinks,
and then I'll pick up
the phone and call Khalil
and he'll be like, I don't
know if that's for the brand.
It's a nice working balance.
And I just love that my
team is able to communicate
with each other effectively,
- They all work together
to achieve the same thing.
- It gets tough when those
lines of communication
aren't good or they start to get blurred.
- Another audience question said,
Kendrick is theatrical would
you do a musical with Kendrick?
- Yes, Kendrick Lamar.
- Kendrick, are you out there?
- I'm gonna talk to him
Whatever y'all are trying
to do as a musical,
I'm fully there for it.
I started my music career
as a songwriter and producer
for musical theater.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, in Atlanta, Georgia.
There's a lot of famous alumni from
the Youth Ensemble of Atlanta.
But I started there my
first gig as a producer.
I was writing I think it
was 25 or 30 original songs
for stage for a two hour long musical
that debuted in Atlanta.
And so I grew up in theater.
So that's why I'm able to
pick that out from Kendrick.
I'm like, oh my God.
- You can see it.
- I can see it.
- So Kendrick, hi, I'm Dixon.
- Yes Dixon, Kendrick.
- Hello, I'm Oscar nominated
if that counts for anything.
- I think it does.
- But yeah, I would love to
do a musical with Kendrick.
There's plenty of artists that I feel like
would be really great
in a musical setting.
Kendrick also sings too.
He has a very special
tone in his singing voice,
but I wouldn't just use him as a rapper.
I would have to use all.
- You really tap into all
of those different facets
of his artistry.
I wanna ask you some a
couple of fun questions
before I let you outta here Dixon.
What do you say?
I mean talking to Oscar's
celebration of movies,
we focus on the awards
when we go to Oscars
and rightfully so, but it's
really a celebration of film.
What is your favorite film
soundtrack of all time?
Or you can name off a couple.
- Okay cool, I was about
to say, I can't really do.
- Yeah, name off a couple.
- I really love School Daze.
It's different.
And there's like the
singles from School Daze.
But the stuff that Dr. Bill Lee
was doing just in the score.
- Spike Lee's father.
- Spike Lee's father,
composer, genius musician.
The stuff that he was doing in the score
was really special.
The openings of the Wake up scene.
it's the opening scene on the soundtrack,
but it's the last scene in the film.
It's one of the most
beautiful pieces of music
I've ever heard in film.
So that's School Daze.
And then one that
doesn't get talked about,
both of mine are spike
Lee, by the way Bamboozled.
- Bamboozled, the mal mouse.
- Jesus Christ Erykah Badu does Hollywood,
the Chaka Khan cover.
It's a crazy soundtrack,
but then to watch the film
and see it in real time.
Also one of my really close friends
who I grew up in theater with his father
was in the film Bamboozled
Thomas Byrd Jefferson who passed.
- Oh yeah, rest in power, great actor.
- Amazing actor, man everything.
- Everything, he always stole a show.
Whenever he came on screen.
- An incredible actor.
- You believed him.
- I believed everything he says.
Even in life and as meeting him in person.
- I'm a little jealous.
- Just an incredible actor.
Also Savion Glover is in Bamboozled
and the music he's creating
with his feet alone
is just it's insane.
So those are two films whose
soundtrack means a lot to me.
- Those are great choices.
- Also honorable mentioned Wayne Casey.
Probably a soundtrack with
the most singles outside
of Car Wash, which is Rose Royce.
My grandfather worked on Car Wash as a DP
and cinematographer.
So those two are my honorable mentions.
Because those are soundtracks
that have the most singles.
- You could just put them on.
And everybody knows the
songs, which is crazy.
I was just listening to
the Car Wash soundtrack
the other day.
I was like man, this thing had
like five or six singles off.
- Which is insane.
- Which means the movie was a hit,
no matter what the industry says.
The movie was a hit
like people loved that music.
- And definitely
a culture bear.
You know what I mean?
Something that impacted
and shaped the culture.
What's the first album that
you paid for with your money
or that you just had to have for yourself.
- You're gonna freak out when I say this.
The first album I ever bought,
my mom had this like CD
subscription thing back in the day.
- Like the RCA Columbia joint?
- Sure it did.
And the first album I
ever received in the mail
was Destiny's Child, The
Writing's On The Wall.
- I mean The Writing's On The Wall.
- No, it's kind of crazy.
I think about it all the time.
- Pretty nuts, did you tell Beyonce that?
- I haven't.
I told Kenny that one time,
I was like the first album I ever bought
with my own money was
The Writing's On The Wall, it's crazy.
- I mean I'm nearly speechless from that.
- I asked my mom the other
day if she remembered
the CD subscription because
I was obsessed with it.
- Yeah, because you get
like 10 or 12 a month.
- What was crazy about this
one is that it was like,
I got my subscription was a little smaller
because I didn't have that much money.
But I would get like a CD every month.
- Wow, that's good.
The first one that ever came
- Was The Writing's On The Wall.
- I mean I think on that note,
you gotta end it on that.
Dixon, congratulations God bless you.
I wish you all the best then
I'm gonna see you Sunday
and then we gonna get up
for that French toast.
- Oh yeah we got to, French toast.
- Peace
- Thanks Bro.
(upbeat music)